good morning Hank it's Tuesday now if
you were trained to the nerdfighters
you're thinking hey that's not John
Green or famous youtuber I'm magic
turtle 6-4-3 50% of the winners selected
for the nerd Factor contest to fill in
for John and his paternity leave
although I'm pretty sure he only picked
me because he loves gingers that's right
kids sometimes it pays to be soulless
but it's okay because I'm actually a
pretty logical replacement for John
Green because like him I use jump cut
jam-packed video blogs to put off making
progress on my novel although it's not
actually a book I'm supposed to be
working on right now I have to give a
lecture on magical realism in exactly a
week to fill a grad school requirement
which is kind of doing a 40 minute video
in one take so let's hope I must own up
don't don't mess up and the lecture is
not done puff levels are high I don't
actually run my hands to my hair when
I'm stressed this is a solidarity puff
but my lecture topic has got me thinking
about magic and the supernatural and I
think the world needs more of it now
that more people need to believe in it
because we know it's all make-believe
but that more people need to make
believe it the thing I find so amazing
about the genre of magical realism is
that the story functions like a
completely realistic novel except the
author adds supernatural elements and
impossible events that break the laws of
nature whenever he or she pleases to add
intrigue and originality and symbolic
residents this is starting to sound like
a grad school lecture I should probably
make a poop joke so this video still
fits comfortably on YouTube and Sarah
Addison Allen's novel the girl who chase
the moon in your pants a character's
ex-husband who is a class-d douche
basket used to leave black dust wherever
he went literally like an ashy powder
would be left behind on everything he
touched her on the shoulders of the
women he wronged which is like a
physical symbol of the messes that
hurtful people leave behind proof of his
black heart as his ex-wife says and
another one of her books the sugar queen
in your pants this girl Chloe is
magically chased around by self-help
books that are trying to solve problems
in her life how much would you pay for
that privilege
I'm going to sing writers like John
Green should ditch the realism stuff I
just think you can never have too much
imagination reality is very limited in
what we can accomplish unless you're
talking about what the brain can
accomplish you can do whatever we want
in movies and books and everyone just
accepts it because for television people
like Hank teach us the rules of physics
and people like John break them I'm not
saying I wish real life had real magic I
guess I am saying that I mean who
wouldn't want to turn a stack of
post-its into a double fudge small
brownie my wife and I made a whole batch
of these for no one except ourselves
four sticks of butter and no regrets but
this began to crease worldsuck with
Harry Potter spells all we can do is
demand more Harry Potter Harry Potter
books are still too
this day captivating people with cranial
sugar Russia's as we put ourselves into
a world where sticks make sparks and
candy explodes although to be honest
with having to look out for all those
evil dark wizards and the lack of
electronics I think I'd rather be a
muggle I mean love potions are great but
you can't bottle the amount of love I
have for my Nintendo 3ds I hope we never
stop obsessing over witches and
superheroes that you've lasers from
their fingertips not because it gives us
false hope or reminds us how boring our
real lives are but because we should
exercise the power to make these things
come true not just with special effects
I mean like you know imagination which
is way better than CGI watching in a
generate an image with my mind I'll
imagine a face and watch a realistic
it'll look or think I need to update my
brain software this one thing I think JK
Rowling got wrong in Harry Potter books
and that's the non-magic folk hate magic
and are in denial of its existence which
I've never found to be true when people
lose their keys they don't come up with
some logical explanation they always
love to say oh my keys were stolen by
ghosts gnomes fairies Pixies cyborg
ninjas because it's more fun that way
again I'm not saying that we should
believe in this stuff just that it's
healthy to fantasize about it now I love
science and hard facts and knowledge as
much as any nerdfighter but I think one
of the best pleasures of say magicians
is not knowing that they performed real
magic but knowing that they made
something amazing happen in a world
where magic isn't possible and that's
what humans are good at I think we make
amazing things happen in a world where
magic isn't possible and sadly I can't
just say decrease IDO world sucky oh and
make everything better but all it takes
is a community of people who love to
read about things that never happened
and sing songs about magical teenagers
to make things a little bit better I
think it went overboard on the special
effects thanks for watching if you want
to see more of me magic turtle 6-4-3
check out the link in the dooblydoo Hank
I'll see you on Friday